ok ahora vas a presionar ejecutar
a la hora de código esto es grandioso la
hora de código la hora de código
tu maestra dice que ustedes lo están
haciendo si lo estamos haciendo es
impresionante
está asociada con 30 distritos escolares
públicos en todo el país incluyendo
nueva york chicago y denver para
proporcionar lecciones de entrenamiento
y de escritura a profesores los más
grandes eventos educativos en la
historia los organizadores se han
propuesto alcanzar lo que ellos llaman
una meta ambiciosa de 10 millones de
estudiantes esta semana casi 15 millones
registrados esta semana estaré orgulloso
de unirme a estudiantes maestros
empresas y organizaciones sin fines de
lucro que están tomando nuevas medidas
para apoyar el aprendizaje de ciencias
de la computación en las escuelas de
eeuu me encontré con una obra de código
es fácil de hacer o lo logré están tan
emocionados con esto
oh dios mío está funcionando lo hice no
tienen que ser ingenieros en ciencias de
la computación tal vez quieran estudiar
otra cosa pero nuestro mundo esto va a
establecer las bases para todo lo que
hagan
punto y coma
estoy tan emocionada estoy programando
cuando estás creando un programa tienes
que pensar desde afuera si puedes
cambiar la tecnología puedes cambiar el
mundo animo a todas los niños de cada
país a aprender una hora de código si
cada distrito lo debería hacer cada
distrito lo puede hacer por favor
ayúdenos a que cada escuela cada salón
de clase y cada niño tenga la hora de
código mi escuela lo está haciendo
ah
[Música]